hey folks Danny here with another gang
spot news update battlefield hardline
has been an open beta and some players
have said it feels more like DLC than a
full price retail release Visceral Games
has responded by describing all the
little differences between hardline in
last year's battlefield 4 League
multiplayer designer Thad sesor explains
some of the differences that make
battlefield hardline a very different
game sessler said the team is focusing
on making hardline specific improvements
to the Frostbite 3 engine to make it
work better with a cops and robbers game
he said we improved the vehicle physics
and so on because in a cops and criminal
setting vehicle collisions are way more
important than in battlefield we're
making fundamental changes under the
hood to some of these systems he also
mentioned the inclusion of new in-game
content he said we've got a wide range
of maps we got a lot of weapons we've
got a lot more cool gadgets we got a lot
more exciting stuff to show you in the
upcoming weeks and months we've got a
slew of new game modes many seem to
agree with gamespot user unreal 849 who
said in the comments more maps more
weapons and more gadgets sure sounds
like an expansion pack to me but what do
you think leave your thoughts in the
comment box below and make sure to stay
tuned to gamespot com for more updates
on the battlefield hardline expansion
game the game the full price retail game